[Musica]
cosa occorre per realizzare un brand di
lusso soldi creatività un prodotto raro
ottimi contatti è possibile oggi in un
mondo così fortemente globale e
competitivo ideare e progettare un brand
di lusso
innanzitutto è importante trovare i
giusti elementi e l'alchimia che li
compone per rispondere a questa domanda
però parto da qualche anno fa da quando
ebbe il tempo di pensare il the aree
progettare la mia idea imprenditoriale a
44 anni dopo vent'anni da davide
l'arrivo di valentina è un sogno
imprenditoriale alle spalle
avevo lavorato per vent'anni nel settore
florovivaistico dove ricoprì diversi
ruoli marketing ufficio acquisti
commerciali vendite aveva un grandissimo
desiderio di realizzare il mio progetto
ma non era ancora arrivato al momento la
gravidanza a rischio e l'obbligo di
rimanere in ospedale almeno per 40
giorni furono per me la svolta perché
decisi che avrei dovuto sfruttare quel
periodo per realizzare il mio sogno
imprenditoriale
mi misi a leggere decine e decine di
libri sul marketing affascinata dai
brand di lusso louis vuitton chanel
ferrari e decisi che quello mi serviva
per ideare per progettare la mia idea
imprenditoriale trovai l'idea per il mio
nuovo progetto imprenditoriale si
trattava di realizzare un prodotto che
andava contro tutto quello in cui
stavano andando in questo momento contro
la guerra dei prezzi a discapito della
qualità ea favore della concorrenza
straniera
eppure si sa che il made in italy
apprezzato in tutto il mondo e tutti ci
apprezzano per la qualità e la
valorizzazione dei nostri prodotti
beh sai subito se con i prodotti della
nostra terra
avrei potuto realizzare con un alchimia
di questi ingredienti un prodotto
lussuoso un prodotto che rappresentasse
la mia liguria e che potesse diventare
l'ambasciatore
pensai ha subito la dualità non so se
avete presente l'opera di michelangelo
pistoletto terzo paradiso che parla
appunto della dualità di due elementi di
due elementi che compongono uno di
durata finita in contrapposizione al
concetto di infinito
esattamente un anno dopo sessi i miei
due elementi
l'olio è loro ma non un olio qualsiasi
l'olio delle olive taggiasche quelle
della nostra terra raccolte
rigorosamente a mano e l'olio filtrato
più volte affinché fosse lucido lucente
ed esse quella brillantezza all'interno
della bottiglia di diamante era quasi
convinta che ha realizzato il mio
prodotto e il mio brand di lusso
inizia così a cercare il secondo
elemento loro
il metallo prezioso e così mi rivolsi ad
uno dei produttori più famosi al mondo
lo stesso che aveva rifornito gualtiero
marchesi con la sua foglia oro per il
risotto famosissimo e conosciuto in
tutto il mondo ottenuto il terzo
elemento dei primi due
avevo bisogno di un vestito e così mi
rivolsi ai ceramisti della provincia di
albisola dalla provincia di savona e
scusatemi al maestro mazzotti di
albisola che creò per la mia bottiglia
d'oro un bellissimo stopper a forma di
diamante rigorosamente realizzato a mano
ci vuole circa un mese per realizzare
questo stop e dipinto in oro 24 carati
nel momento in cui realizzare questo
prodotto
ero convinta che era arrivata un buon
passo e come potevo finalmente riuscire
a presentarlo per posizionarlo nel brand
di lusso e questa è stata la cosa più
difficile perché ancora oggi è
un'attività che non si ferma mai
dopo circa un anno decise che era
arrivato il momento di lanciarlo sul
mercato
e così avevo bisogno di posizionarlo ma
come potevo fare pensai a un evento a un
evento importante e decisi di spendere
quasi il 50 60 300 del mio budget
però mi sembrava folle in quel momento
però avevo capito che soltanto in quel
modo potevo far percepire il mio grande
come un brand di lusso fu così che
realizzai un evento maestoso
scenografico bellissimo nella sala degli
squali a genova presso l'acquario e
invita i 80 persone 80 persone tra
manager avvocati imprenditori che erano
a conoscenza del mercato internazionale
e dell'export loro sarebbero stati il
mio target le persone che avrebbero
dovuto dare un valore al mio prodotto
esatto perché io dovevo in quel momento
far percepire quale era il valore del
mio prodotto perché forse come sapete è
difficile trovare un prezzo per un brand
di lusso perché naturalmente il prezzo
di un brand di lusso non è esattamente
proporzionale non è direttamente
proporzionale agli elementi che lo
compongono
decise così di creare un'esperienza
un'esperienza unica e quella fu
veramente il mio debutto perché quella
serata in quella serata dove ripeto
spesi quasi circa il 50 60 per cento del
mio budget riuscì a creare un'esperienza
meravigliosa con oggetti di arredamento
di design importanti e una scenografia
favolosa una mise en plus è fantastica e
fu veramente il debutto importante
e proprio in quell evento li riuscì a
dare un prezzo è un valore che
l'entusiasmo dei miei ospiti che
cominciarono proprio loro stessi a dare
un valore al mio brand e lì nacquero i
primi due contatti importanti i miei
primi due brand ambassador che poi
portarono a oulx e nel mondo ma non fini
qui avevo bisogno di un vero debutto di
personaggi che andassero al di fuori dei
miei invitati e arrivo dopo circa tre
mesi nuovamente una chiamata importante
e a volte se ci penso pensavo fosse uno
scarso sinceramente il principe alberto
da montecarlo con un evento di 300
persone
invitati da tutto il mondo per un evento
internato internazionale per un evento
benefico vmt sans frontière
e in quell'occasione sono ancora
emozionata adesso che ci penso
il principe alberto aveva messo a uno e
uno come primo premio davanti a drenthe
internazionali e fu per me una
grandissima emozione riuscì a capire il
proprio in quel momento che
probabilmente aule home sarebbe
diventato una bassa della nostra
italianità in quell evento con abi
moltissimi persone che mi aiutarono poi
per il posizionamento ma fu definitivo
la conoscenza di un ambassador che mi
presentò il vietnam
io pensavo di andare a target sui paesi
arabi perché solitamente quando si
realizza un prodotto così di lusso il
primo paese il paese sono i paesi arabi
invece per una serie di eventi mi
ritrovai in vietnam e il vietnam con mio
grande stupore perché era una località
pazzesca in forte crescita con un amava
il lusso lo adorava l'accoglienza che mi
fecero era veramente strepitosa ma
soprattutto c'erano persone alto
spendenti pensate che ci sono soggetti
che hanno una disponibilità economica di
oltre 30 milioni di dollari
ancora più di cina ed india questo mi
stupì e riuscì a entrare in locali
famosissimi in catene alberghiere
importanti e nei ristoranti stellati
riviste internazionali e locali e
nazionali cominciarono a parlare di noi
dal financial time arter basare
repubblica stampa e il corriere della
sera cioè tutta la stampa in modo
organico perché la cosa che poi è quello
che ci aspettiamo no non quello di
pagare della pubblicità ma quello che
parlino di noi in modo organico
cominciava a parlare di quest'olio come
l'olio più bello al mondo e per noi fu
veramente un grandissimo una grandissima
soddisfazione un grandissimo successo
con questo progetto abbiamo sostenuto
diverse iniziative perché è molto
importante per un'impresa per un'azienda
non dimenticare mai la mission e abbiamo
sostenuto attività internazionali come a
me the sun fontiere orange iniziative in
vietnam
cio tra cuba e save the woman
il nostro voglio comunque ancora oggi e
sulle tavole dei ristoranti più famosi
al mondo e quello che mi fa piacere e
che viene riconosciuto come un brand
basse di delle sanità quindi una cosa
che comunque lo ha reso molto iconico e
il fatto che noi non abbiamo mai venduto
né online nei commerce questo perché
sono stati proprio i brand ambassador
a presentarlo e a posizionarlo perché
una cosa molto importante è un prodotto
particolare un prodotto che va
raccontato che deve emozionare
quindi è un prodotto che comunque deve
essere posizionato da dalla persona
perché la persona riesce a raccontare le
emozioni e la storia che c'è dietro
questo prodotto
abbiamo scelto che questo canale ovvero
quello di utilizzare tra virgolette le
persone e non negli strumenti anche se
vi dirò che durante l'evento in via che
non abbiamo utilizzato un tavolo
interattivo per raccontare la storia di
questo prodotto un tavolo interattivo
fatto interamente in liguria quindi
anche anche qui è diventato l'ambassade
diversi della della dell'italianità ma
anche ed è proprio della liguria quindi
abbiamo unito più aziende liguri per
presentare un progetto unico dato dalla
dal gusto dal sapore e quindi della
nostra terra dall'artigianalità e anche
della tecnologia
quindi diciamo che racchiude un po e
diverse anime quindi se oggi mi chiedete
qual è la ricetta del lusso di risponde
stravolgete gli schemi
cercate la via difficile più difficile
perché quella meno trafficata e non
fermatevi al primo ostacolo lavorate
sempre con passione con amore e
valorizzate ogni piccolo successo ma
soprattutto guardatemi con gli occhi di
stranieri che vedono l'italia come un
mito del lusso del design e della
creatività
[Applauso]